[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Nächste Woche ist ja Valentinstag.
Murat und ich haben ja bereits am Mittwoch schon
ein leckeres und sehr
aufregendes Rezept für euch gemacht,
nämlich Pralinen, einen Pralinen-Workshop für zwei.
Also, falls ihr noch nicht wisst,
was ihr an Valentinstag machen wollt,
– es muss ja eh jeder zu Hause bleiben –
dann macht doch Pralinen zusammen
oder mit eurer besten Freundin
oder mit eurem besten Freund.
Egal. Es macht jedenfalls viel Spaß und es war sehr witzig.
Jetzt, habe ich mir gedacht, mache ich eine Mini-Torte,
so eine Mini-Torte für zwei.
Okay, die reicht wahrscheinlich am Ende
für vier oder für sechs.
Aber zumindest so eine kleine Torte,
die man einfach nachbacken kann.
Und ich habe mich für eine Nougat-Torte entschieden.
Denn wir haben in unserem Team
einen Nougat-Liebhaber
hinter der Kamera.
>> JOSH: Wer könnte das denn sein?
>> SALLY: Das ist derjenige,
der den Nougat immer frittiert haben will,
auf Eis, im Kuchen,
im Porridge, überall.
Jedenfalls, habe ich mir jetzt gedacht,
mache ich einen Rührkuchen
mit Haselnüssen, Kakao und Zucker.
Das ist ja schon die Grundmasse für Nougat.
Und später in der Creme nehmen wir dann,
Josh, natürlich Nougat-Creme.
>> JOSH: Yes!
>> SALLY: Dafür nehme ich 50 Gramm Haselnüsse,
zwei Eier,
80 Gramm Zucker,
eine Prise Salz,
etwas Vanilleextrakt,
40 Gramm Espresso,
80 Gramm Sonnenblumenöl,
90 Gramm Mehl,
einen Teelöffel Backpulver
und 20 Gramm Kakao.
Das sind die Zutaten.
Es sind gar nicht so viele.
Und was ich jetzt zuerst machen werde:
die Haselnüsse zerkleinern.
Ich nehme da immer ganze Nüsse
und mahle die dann selber,
weil dann das Aroma einfach viel intensiver schmeckt.
Das mache ich jetzt hier kurz.
[Musik]
Und am besten die Haselnüsse direkt in eine Pfanne mahlen.
Dann könnt ihr sie nämlich direkt anrösten,
einfach ohne Fett.
Und ab und zu rühren, bis sie lecker duften.
Und in der Zwischenzeit
kann ich schon mal die Eier
mit dem Zucker, Salz und Vanilleextrakt schaumig rühren.
[Musik]
Und jetzt für etwa fünf bis zehn Minuten cremig rühren.
Ich glaube, so lange braucht es gar nicht.
Fünf bis sechs Minuten.
[Musik]
Schön sieht das aus.
So. Und jetzt kann ich im Prinzip alle Zutaten reingeben.
Oh, die lasse ich noch ganz kurz abkühlen.
Hier der Kaffee und das Öl.
Wenn ihr gar keinen Kaffee mögt,
könnt ihr den auch weglassen
und ein bisschen Buttermilch oder Sprudel
oder auch einen Haselnusslikör dazu geben.
Passt auch gut,
weil Haselnuss und Haselnusskuchen.
Der Josh lacht.
>> JOSH: Das wäre, glaube ich, schon was für mich.
>> SALLY: Ja, gell?
>> JOSH: Voll. Ja.
>> SALLY: So. Dann
die trockenen Zutaten sieben.
[Musik]
Ich finde es immer gut,
wie du mich mit deiner Oma vergleichst.
>> JOSH: Nicht wie die Oma,
das Sieb.
Ja.
>> SALLY: Ja. Ich finde es voll süß.
Weil dann weiß ich,
so, wie ich backe, hat deine Oma schon gebacken
und dann hast du schon so einen positiven Eindruck
und dann magst du mein Essen auch.
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: So.
>> JOSH: Also wer kann ein Einhandsieb nicht mögen?
>> SALLY: Ja, nicht?
Jetzt die Zutaten kurz einrühren
und wirklich nur kurz, bis sie sich verbunden haben.
Ja. Ich habe ja schon erwähnt, wir machen eine kleine Torte.
Und ich nehme jetzt hier zwei Mini-Backringe,
habe die auf 14 cm eingestellt.
Ihr könnt den Teig aber auch in einen Backring einfüllen.
Wenn er höher ist, hat er halt eine längere Backzeit.
Das ist so der Unterschied.
Und ich mache es jetzt direkt auf zwei.
Es verkürzt sich die Backzeit, ich bin schneller fertig
und außerdem passen ja auch zwei gut in den Backofen.
Die sind ja so süß!
[Musik]
Jetzt kommt der Kuchen in den Backofen.
Ich denke, die Backzeit, die ist nicht länger als 15 Minuten.
Und sobald die kalt sind, geht es direkt an die Nougat-Creme.
Wobei, die kann ich währenddessen schon machen.
[Musik]
Für die Nougat Creme nehme ich
50 Gramm weiche Butter,
300 Gramm Frischkäse,
200 Gramm Nuss-Nougat-Creme
und einen Esslöffel Kakao.
Dann könnt ihr jetzt die Butter weich rühren,
den Frischkäse, den Nougat und Kakao dazu geben.
Und dann wird das gleich eine leckere, cremige Konsistenz.
[Musik]
Perfekt!
Und wenn die Böden jetzt ausgekühlt sind,
kann die Torte direkt gefüllt werden.
[Musik]
Jetzt kann ich hier die Böden durchschneiden
und das Mini-Törtchen füllen.
Ich mache das jetzt mal so.
Oh, wie schön!
Ich nehme die zwei Deckel
und steche in der Mitte ein Loch aus.
[Musik]
Das wird ein Überraschungsfach.
Hm.
Und jetzt kann ich diesen flachen Boden hier hinstellen.
Das war ein bisschen Creme für so ein kleines Törtchen.
[Musik]
Ja.
So passt es.
[Musik]
Dann ein
– huch!
Okay, so klein sind sie doch nicht.
Dann ein Lochboden.
Wieder Creme.
[Musik]
Das ist immer das Problem.
Wenn man so lockere Tortenböden hat,
sind die halt auch schwieriger zu bestreichen.
Aber ich finde, die Mühe lohnt sich.
Denn es schmeckt halt besser als so ein fester Kuchen, der
einfach trocken ist.
So.
Der ist gar nicht so hoch, wie ich dachte.
Mh.
Wisst ihr was? Damit mehr Überraschung reinpasst,
löchere ich noch den da oben.
Ja.
Und jetzt einmal schon mal ein bisschen Creme außenrum,
damit diese Krümelchen schon mal gebunden werden.
[Musik]
So. Die Torte stelle ich jetzt mal kurz in den Kühlschrank.
Denn bei uns ist es hier drin
einfach zu warm
Und dann geht es gleich weiter.
Die Torte war jetzt in der Kühlung über Nacht.
Denn bei uns in der Küche hatte es, glaube ich, 28°C.
Ich glaube, in Konditoreien hat man immer
so 17/18°C in der Stube,
und wir halt so 28°C.
Mir war es halt kalt morgens.
Okay.
Ich habe mir jetzt aber Folgendes noch überlegt über Nacht.
Ich wollte jetzt den untersten Boden auch noch durchstechen.
Ich muss es jetzt aber kurz wegschneiden,
damit einfach direkt beim Aufschneiden
die Herzchen rausfallen können.
Das heißt, einfach alle Böden
durchschneiden.
Ja, guckt mal. Jetzt geht es doch viel besser.
Also man muss halt echt sagen,
Kühlzeit ist so das Wichtigste beim Backen
und die Geduld.
Jetzt einmal komplett drumherum glatt streichen.
Und dann mache ich immer erst den Rand
und dann die Oberfläche.
Und immer wieder die Palette am Rand säubern.
Dann habt ihr einen schönen glatten Übergang.
[Musik]
Dann noch hier innen glätten.
Ich fühle mich gerade
wie in so einem Töpferkurs
mit diesem Ding.
Es ist eigentlich ähnlich,
nur schmeckt es besser.
Dann stelle ich die Torte jetzt noch mal schnell kühl.
Und guckt mal. Ich habe jetzt hier zwei Schüsseln.
Und zwar die eine Schüssel
ist die Schüssel mit der Creme und den Keksbröseln
– Kuchenbröseln.
Und die andere Schüssel ist die mit der Creme,
die eben noch schön sauber ist.
Das heißt, in der Creme sind jetzt keine Brösel drin.
Die kann ich später einfach naschen
und die hier nehme ich gleich.
Denn die Oberfläche der Torte wird ja noch dekoriert
und da brauche ich einfach eine Creme ohne Brösel drin.
Die soll schön glatt sein.
Die stelle ich jetzt kurz ins Gefrierfach
oder in den Kühlschrank.
Und dann suche ich schon mal Streusel raus
und werde diese Creme
noch mal mit Kakao ein bisschen dunkler färben.
Und dann dekorieren wir sie fertig.
Dann ist sie nämlich gleich durch.
Die wäre schon dunkel gewesen,
wenn ich Zartbitter-Nougat genommen hätte.
Aber ich hatte keine Zartbitter-Nougat-Creme.
>> JOSH: Ah!
>> SALLY: Nein!
Jetzt habe ich sie dir zartbitter gemacht, Josh.
>> JOSH: Ja!
>> SALLY: Gut.
Dann werde ich die Torte
noch einmal von außen glätten.
Hm.
>> JOSH: Wobei, das hält sich ja nicht lang, oder?
>> SALLY: Ach!
Oh, wir hätten aber Banane so auf
– also zwischen die Dinger legen können,
hätte ich gewusst,
dass du Banane und Nougat magst als Kombi.
Und dann würde ich euch jetzt empfehlen,
die Torte ganz kurz einzufrieren,
damit sie kalt wird
und ihr sie dann eben schön umsetzen könnt.
Weil, wenn ich sie jetzt umsetze,
dann schmiere ich einfach diese Nougat-Creme
noch mal drumherum.
Deswegen friert sie kurz ein.
Also nehmt euch da die Zeit
und das ist jetzt auch wirklich eine Mini-Torte,
also die sollte eigentlich in jedes Gefrierfach passen.
Und dann setze ich sie auf eine Mini-Palette
– Mini-Platte.
Vor lauter Palette.
Es ist ja eine Mini-Torte,
also gibt es auch Mini-Spritzbeutel.
Und ich nehme jetzt auch Mini-Spritztüllen.
Ich würde jetzt hier einfach mal die nehmen.
Das ist so eine flache Tülle,
die aber vorne so fein gezackt ist.
Dann über ein Glas stülpen.
Ich habe nämlich keinen Mini-Spritzbeutelständer.
Aber so ein Glas tut es ja auch.
Aber das wäre schon süß, gell?
So ein kleiner.
Nein, Sally, man braucht nicht alles.
Dann am besten jetzt schon mal die Torte umsetzen.
[Musik]
Dann kommen da jetzt die Streusel rein.
Also bei mir kommt jetzt hier
– einfach so kleine rosa Herzchen und Perlen
kommen jetzt hier rein.
Ihr könnt aber auch eine Botschaft verstecken.
Ihr könnt im Prinzip auch Fruchtgummis verstecken.
Alles, was ihr möchtet, was ihr lecker findet,
kann da drin Platz finden.
Ich werde das allerdings kurz durchmischen müssen.
Denn ich habe die da so geschichtet,
aber ich will es ja kunterbunt gemischt.
Und ich dachte mir, von der Größe
– doch das passt.
[Musik]
Dann hatte ich hier diese ausgestochenen Teile aufgehoben.
Und die sind jetzt auch super.
Ich werde sie wahrsch-
– nee, ich glaube, ich probiere es so.
Das nicht, den oberen.
Ich schneide es ein bisschen flach.
Perfekt!
Ein bisschen Cremen zum Abdecken.
So sieht keiner mehr die Überraschung.
Schön versteckt.
Da könnt ihr auch einen Ring drin verstecken.
Schneidet ihn nur nicht durch.
Und entweder könnt ihr jetzt noch einen Drip drauf machen,
wobei ich finde, die Torte ist jetzt nicht hoch genug
für einen schönen Drip.
Ich würde jetzt einfach mit dieser Tülle
eine Spritztechnik mal ausprobieren
und zwar
eine Bordüre.
Und die würde ich gern auf die gesamte Oberfläche machen.
Wenn es nicht gut aussieht, nehme ich es wieder runter.
Ja. Wenn nicht, könnt ihr aber auch eine Tülle nehmen
wie zum Beispiel
diese hier.
Damit könnt ihr gute Tupfen machen.
Oder auch diese hier.
Oder
– upsala. Die sind so klein.
Oder auch diese Blütentülle.
Damit kann man auch richtig schöne Tupfen machen.
Ich mache jetzt gleich so eine Spritztechnik drauf
von innen nach außen.
Und wenn ihr möchtet, könnt ihr euch
mit Ringen zum Beispiel eine Markierung setzen.
Denn es ist nicht immer einfach.
Vor allem, wenn man dann anfängt einmal,
dann findet man vielleicht nicht immer sofort die Mitte.
Deswegen macht euch da ein paar Ringe hin.
Und dann fange ich jetzt mittig an
und werde jetzt die Tortenplatte drehen
und während des Drehens
immer so eine Wellenbewegung machen.
Okay?
Und ich mache das Ganze immer in so einer Endlosspirale.
Also die geht jetzt nicht Reihe für Reihe,
sondern in einem durch.
Und wenn ihr mal absetzen müsst,
dann immer unten absetzen.
Dann könnt ihr nämlich hier oben wieder ansetzen.
[Musik]
Und damit es ein bisschen nach Valentinstag aussieht
von außen,
streue ich hier noch kleine
Streusel dran,
aber nur ganz wenige.
[Musik]
So.
Und jetzt kommt sie in die Kühlung.
Und dann schaue ich mal, wer sie probieren darf.
[Musik]
Ach Gott, ist die süß!
Und so klein!
[Musik]
Oh!
Wobei die Spritztülle fast schon zu groß war.
Ich hätte echt die kleinere nehmen können.
Oh!
[Musik]
>> JOSH: Ist schon
schon süß.
>> SALLY: So.
Die ist für dich, darfst du probieren.
>> JOSH: Oh!
Danke.
>> SALLY: So.
Aufräumen.
[Musik]
Jetzt ist das Valentinstagstörtchen fertig.
Und natürlich bekommt das
mein Valentin, wollte ich sagen, mein Törtchen.
The one and only,
das schwäbische Kirschtörtchen,
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Murat.
>> MURAT: Bitte nenn mich nicht Törtchen.
Meine Arbeitskollegen schauen zu.
>> SALLY: Ich habe dich schon mal Törtchen genannt
vor einigen Jahren im Fernsehen.
>> MURAT: Nenn mich lieber Steak oder so was.
>> SALLY: Also ich habe für dich eine Torte gebacken
zum Valentinstag.
>> MURAT: Okay.
>> SALLY: Ein Mini-Törtchen für zwei!
>> MURAT: Also...
>> SALLY: Ich habe jetzt zwei Tage gebacken, Schatz.
>> MURAT: Wow!
>> MURAT: Wirklich?
Was für
– ist das für Valentinstag to go?
So einfach kurz reinnehmen und zack, weg.
Ist das dein Ernst jetzt?
>> SALLY: Das ist die...
>> MURAT: Ist das eine Fake-Torte?
Das ist ja...
Aber süß ist sie. Wirklich.
>> SALLY: Ja. Okay, die ist für den Josh.
>> MURAT: Soll das eine Anspielung sein
auf mich irgendwie oder so was?
>> SALLY: Nein.
>> MURAT: Ja. Wolltest du mich gerade haten?
>> SALLY: Das hier ist die Torte.
>> MURAT: Oh!
Ja, das sieht schon wieder anders aus.
>> SALLY: Ich habe sie schon angeschnitten.
Dann kommen da so oh, so Herzchen raus.
>> MURAT: Ach, cool! Das ist ein Surprise Cake.
>> SALLY: Süß, nicht?
>> MURAT: Okay.
Schokotorte geht natürlich immer.
Ganz cool.
>> SALLY: Ich wollte dich natürlich überraschen
mit Goldtalern und so,
– keine Ahnung –
so irgendwie was Männlichem, was rausfällt.
Keine Ahnung.
>> MURAT: Was ist
– WD-40.
Da läuft gerade WD-40 raus.
Wow!
Genau. Richtig cool!
Nee, aber...
>> SALLY: Aber dann dachte ich so, ach komm,
so Herzchen sind doch süß.
>> MURAT: Okay. Ich meine, ich stehe voll auf rosa Herzchen,
muss ich ehrlich sagen.
>> SALLY: Ich weiß!
>> MURAT: Ja.
Okay.
>> SALLY: Oh!
Können wir uns noch kurz romantisch angucken?
>> MURAT: Ja, aber nur ganz kurz.
>> SALLY: Komm. Wir machen es wie bei der Hochzeitstorte.
>> MURAT: Nein. Entschuldigung, Schatz. Ich finde das voll...
Ich finde das voll klischeehaft. Wirklich.
>> SALLY: Komm. Wie bei unserer Hochzeitstorte.
Aber ich kann das große Ding da...
>> MURAT: Ach so.
>> SALLY: Warte.
>> MURAT: Bei der Hochzeit machen man das, gell?
Aber das macht man, glaube ich, in allen Kulturen,
ob es in der türkischen oder deutschen ist, oder, Josh?
Das macht man doch auch bei
– bei einer deutschen Hochzeit
macht man das doch auch, oder?
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Komm, wir tauschen die Gabeln.
Meine sieht eleganter aus.
>> MURAT: Ja.
Okay.
>> SALLY: Okay. Eins, zwei, drei.
[Oh-Rufe]
>> MURAT: Mmh!
Mmh!
Cool!
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> MURAT: Eine coole Schokotorte.
>> SALLY: Oh, jetzt haben wir die Gabeln getauscht.
Aber ist okay, oder?
>> MURAT: Ich finde das immer so...
Ich weiß es nicht, warum man das macht.
>> SALLY: Wir sind ein Haushalt.
>> MURAT: Ich finde das voll klischeehaft.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> MURAT: Wenn ihr heiratet, macht das.
Ich finde das jetzt...
>> SALLY: Bei der Hochzeit?
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> JOSH: Nicht immer mehrfach?
>> MURAT: Wenn man sich das in den Mund so
und dann macht man Fotos.
Und ich finde das...
Dann guckt man sich das irgendwann später an.
>> SALLY: Okay, vielleicht bei türkischen Hochzeiten.
>> MURAT: Also ich schäme mich dafür. Ganz ehrlich.
>> SALLY: Echt? Ich kenne da so einen Videoausschnitt.
>> MURAT: Nein! Nein, bitte! Hör doch auf mit den Videos.
Wenn es etwas gibt, was ich hasse, sind es Hochzeitsvideos.
Das ist wirklich das Schlimmste, was ist.
Mein Hochzeitsvideo ist für mich ein Horrorfilm.
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Und um unsere Romantik
an den Höhepunkt zu bringen
– ich meine, im Videorahmen.
>> MURAT: Mache ich jetzt einen auf Magic Mike.
>> SALLY: Kannst du dich einmal
auf den Boden schmeißen wie Magic Mike?
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Um unsere Romantik
an ihren Höhepunkt zu bringen,
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: – verdreht mir nicht die Wörter im Mund! –
>> SALLY: möchte ich das mit einem Liebesduett abschließen.
>> MURAT: Nein! Bitte!
Nein, bitte, Schatz, mach das nicht.
Ich will echt nicht singen. Bitte.
>> SALLY: I found a love
>> MURAT: Hm.
Mmm.
>> SALLY: for me!
>> MURAT: Schatz, ich kann das irgendwie echt nicht.
Ich will echt nicht singen.
>> SALLY: Darling,
>> MURAT: Nee. Bitte, Schatz. Wirklich.
>> SALLY: just dive right in...
>> MURAT: Nein, es ist schon echt...
Das ist schon...
Tut mir wirklich leid.
War echt lecker!
Also macht die Torte daheim nach.
Die ist echt super,
hat mir geschmeckt.
So.
Mmh!
Ich liebe dich.
Alles Gute zum Valentinstag.
>> SALLY: We were just kids when we fell
in
>> MURAT & SALLY: love
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: not knowing what it was!
>> MURAT: Okay, alles klar.
Tschüss! Macht's gut!
>> SALLY: I will not
>> MURAT: Ich wünsche euch einen frohen Valentinstag
>> SALLY: give you up
>> MURAT: mit euren Lieben zusammen.
>> SALLY: this time!
>> MURAT: Tschüss!
Schatz, mach aus, gell?
>> SALLY: Darling, just kiss me slow!
Du hättest einfach mit einsteigen sollen.
>> MURAT: Nein.
[Musik]